- On this episode I talk Italian ices,
self promotion up front in the video,
and the Jets?
If I don't buy them, who do I buy?
You keep asking questions, I'll
keep trying to answer them.
Hey everybody, this is
Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and you're watching
the #AskGaryVee show,
episode number 23.
Little fun fact about the number 23 is
a lot of people like that number.
It's because there was
was a basketball player
that used to play.
His name was Michael Jordan,
and everybody liked him so much
and thought he was so great.
But not this guy.
I hate Michael Jordan.
- [Voiceover] Brian asks,
"Should I post articles
"on my blog and mention on social
"or post natively on sites
"like Linkedin, Medium,
and Facebook, or both?"
- Brian, great question,
and it's a loaded question,
because you've probably looked at
the new garyvaynerchuk.com
(ding)
and you probably realized
that I'm doing a mix.
Like, you know, you land on a page
and I've got the place for
Medium posts and Linkedin posts.
When you land on it, some of the posts
literally link out to Linkedin and Medium,
and then obviously I have my own posts,
and actually, Steve and
I were just talking.
Did we put up the first post where it's
just for garyvaynerchuk.com?
- [Steve] Yes, we did.
- Got it.
So that's there too.
And so what I think is
interesting about this question
is most people in the
internet marketing world
want to keep telling you
to do it on your own site,
monetize your own traffic, it's yours,
Facebook reach can't be taken away.
All this "own it, own it, own it."
The problem with "own it, own it, own it"
is when you're doing it on your own site,
you're at the mercy of how much traffic
you're able to establish on your own site,
and so from the 99.999% of
you that are watching this
that don't have four million unique people
coming to your site
every day, every month,
the reality is is placed like Medium,
for example, I had a
Medium go extremely viral,
viral as in it did really well on Medium,
and right now it's sitting
as number six or seven
on Medium's top stories where I've noticed
that 950 people have clicked
over and read the article
because of that place,
and that's 950 people
that I'm gonna guess 787 of them
have never even heard of me before.
And so too many people are worried about
monetizing the now, posting on their page,
versus using things like
Linkedin and Medium,
and notice I use those two
because they have viral loops.
Linkedin, when articles go
well, it shows up in Pulse.
Medium sends out an email
and has the top stories.
So I like being in places
where there's viral loops,
that if you put out a
nice piece of content,
I noticed the kid on
Twitter today tweet out,
"Hey, I'm number four on Medium,
"two spots ahead of Gary V,"
and then I looked at his profile
and he has 1,400 Twitter followers,
and that got me excited, I'm like
"See, great content can raise to the top
and bring awareness,"
and so I think a heavy mix of both.
I'm a big fan of picking
spots strategically
that give you awareness and
then builds leverage for you
that then eventually you can
monetize in your own world.
- [Voiceover] Sean asks, "You
are always answering questions
"about business, brands, et cetera.
"What's the one life
lesson you have learned
"since becoming a father?"
- Sean, this is a fun question for me.
I appreciate it.
You know, I love this show because
I'm really shooting straight,
and in me shooting straight
you're gonna all really realize
how much of a contradiction I really am.
You're gonna figure out how
much of an ego I actually have.
much humility I actually have.
This is gonna go on the ego side.
I've always been nurturing.
I love HR and the team, and
like, you guys, the community.
I have a lot of nurturing DNA.
I'm a motherly kind of character.
I also have an 11 year younger brother
that gave me a test run into fatherhood,
because my brother and I have
that kind of relationship,
especially cause my dad
is such a workaholic,
wasn't around as much.
Though much more for AJ than me,
I just want to throw that out there.
He did go to some of his basketball games,
which I'm still jealous about,
and in general my dad's
kind of an old-school,
less nurturing, let's put
it that way, kind of guy,
and so, you know, when
I'm 19, AJ is eight.
What that did for me in a lot of ways was,
you know, it's not the same.
A brother, even as much as I love AJ,
it's a different feeling from children.
I think the thing that it's taught me is,
I want to say unconditional
love, but the truth is
I probably love my parents and siblings
more than the average person
from what I've been able to gather.
It's taught me things I knew, which is
the fear that I have for any,
Misha, yesterday, talking to me about
somebody called her a chatterbox
and it hurt her feelings.
A, made me laugh, because
she's like her dad,
and I'm like, I remember going,
"My music teacher in first grade called me
"a machine mouth," or
something pretty tough.
Anyway, motor mouth, thank you.
So she's going through that
stuff and it was crazy to me
to sit there and feel how much pain I felt
and we're not even in bullying zone,
or zits zone, or awkward teen years zone,
so it's teaching me that,
as much as I love my parents
and my siblings and
all these other things,
the love I have for those two is deep,
and it's hardcore.
- Hey Gary.
Tony Brown here from tonylbrown.com,
creator of the 3V strategy--
- This guy.
- I'm just going through my
- Nice hustle.
- Instagram timeline,
and I've just seen a post
from Instagram, telling me
they're gonna start advertising
on the timeline in the UK.
It had over 6,300 comments,
many of which were saying, "No, no, no,
"you're gonna ruin it,
and bye bye Instagram."
You always say marketers ruin everything.
What are your thoughts on that?
- Couple things--
- Great show, I love it.
- Keep it up.
- Sorry.
- And I'll speak to you again soon.
- Speak to you soon.
Couple things.
Look, first of all, there's
a lot of different audiences.
For example, 99% of
people that run a Q&A show
would not allow a question to be aired
where the person spent the first 9%
of the question promoting himself.
But I love the hustle, right?
So there's that.
Two, do you know how many Americans,
and I know you're from the UK,
you know how many Americans
said they would leave America
and move to Canada when
George Bush got reelected?
And then vice versa when Obama
got elected and reelected,
how many of my friends and
elitists and rich peeps
and poor peeps said they're
gonna move to Canada if X, Y, Z.
The amount of things we say versus
the amount of things we do
is a very big difference,
and that's why Instagram
isn't worried about that,
because I,
Tony, you want to have a
real, fun, little test?
Go back into that post and
then go click all the people
that said, "Bye bye, Instagram"
and see how many pictures they've posted
since they've commented.
My guess?
A lot more.
So the question and answer
to your question is,
so the answer to your question.
You don't edit.
I'm so scared of DRock's editing,
cause we edit a little more on this show
than we did with Wine Library,
and I'm a little scared, because I know
we're trying to be efficient
and DRock's skilled.
Don't take that personal, DRock.
But don't edit that crap.
Never edit any of my mistakes
or any of my blub ups.
Let's start with that.
If you're editing just for time
reasons, I can respect that.
So to answer your question
is I think it's a nonevent,
of course there's a
certain level of hippies
that will go off of that
platform because of that,
but if Instagram finds its right rythym
the way Facebook has, I don't
see anything really happening,
and so I just think it's a nonevent.
- [Voiceover] Johnny asks,
"If the Jets never come up
"for sale in your lifetime,
and another NFL team does,
"would you buy that team instead?"
- Johnny, one of the things I
worried about with this show
was answering questions
I don't like to answer,
and this is one of them.
At this point, I've ebb and flowed with this.
At this point, my belief is that
I would really focus on the Knicks,
and then after that, a
random basketball team.
So it goes Jets, Knicks,
That's your answer.
- [Voiceover] Matt asks,
"How would you promote
"a Kickstarter campaign
beyond providing content
"to raise awareness and
reach funding goals?"
- Matt, you know.
(stammers)
I'm bumbling on this.
No, no, I'm sticking, DRock,
I just fucking told you
that I'm not editing
on any of my mistakes.
Jesus with this guy.
All you editors are the same,
want to take out the natural, authentic.
You guys like when I
struggle with my words
cause it happens so rarely.
(ding)
I treat Kickstarter no
different than anything else.
Just cause you have an ice
thing that you want to do
and you decide to do it on Kickstarter
because that's a platform
that has virality,
back to the question
about Medium and Linkedin,
that's fine.
The answer is the same.
Facebook dark posts, targeting
people that give a crap
about ice cream and ices,
putting out content in blog form.
Guest contributing.
I would literally email
every single person
that has a blog of any size or magnitude
that plays in your space.
I didn't look deeply, but
if you're in organic ices
or just ices, or desserts
or ice cream culture,
I would map out the 700
people that are in that space
that have blogs or media outlets
and reach out to them and say,
"I'd like to guest contribute."
Talk about Italian ices or ice cream
or dessert culture in America
or the world, generally,
not spamming like, "I want to
tell you about my product."
It's all about being content
and not being about infomercials.
Too many of the people watching this show
and the rest of the world,
when they think about content
they hear Billy Mays, an infomercial.
When I think about content,
I hear New York Times and Scandal.
Get it?
It's about making that decision,
and so getting distribution,
putting out good content,
and that means guest contributing,
Facebook dark posts if you've
got money to drive towards it,
reaching out to influencers and chefs
that are in the dessert space to see if
you can JV what I would
call business development.
"Hey," you know, "Mario Batali,"
"Here's what I can do for you.
"Give you 8% of my company if you
"can get me the spark that
starts out my awareness.
"Hey, Carla Hall, I think you're amazing
"in your southern cusisine, I'll give you
"five years worth of my product for free
"if you give me a little love.
"How can you give me love?
"A tweet's not enough."
So it's biz dev, it's content creation
that's not infomercial but actual content,
and then it's proper internet marketing,
which right now to me is creme dela creme
is Facebook dark posts.
You've been watching the #AskGaryVee show.
My question of the day
for you is very simple.
What are you dressing up as for Halloween?
You keep asking questions, I
will continue to answer them.
His name was Michael Jordan,
and everybody liked him
so much and thought he was so great.
But not this guy.
I hate Michael Jordan.
Knicks fan, and there's no
reason to like Michael Jordan.
Why would in the world
would I like that dude?
(bleep) him.
Oh crap, wait.
Subscribe!
(tooting noises)
I need subscriptions because I can't push
this many right hooks in social.